let's go next to Bert from New Jersey
Bert from New Jersey welcome please save
us let's hope your connection is better
than the last two have been
hey David how's my connection it's
beautiful so far
awesome awesome thanks for uh picking on
me pleasure
um here's my question uh when people
criticize Biden yes uh from the from the
right typically right
first thing they talk about is inflation
this is Biden's economy Biden's
inflation bite inflation right
um the very nature of how inflation
occurs as you increase the money supply
right
so Trump in four years increased the
money supply more than any U.S president
in the history of our country in a
four-year span right
so my my question is
um why don't people call that out where
okay your your guess inflation will how
are you for Trump then that conversation
well increasing the money supply
depending on how it's done and for what
purposes can have an inflationary effect
it is not a guarantee that it does so I
think at least we on the left want to be
a little more uh precise with with that
and tactical in terms of when when we
when we bring it up but you're right
that at least as far as the right is
concerned that is true and listen you
this is not new ground in the sense that
I've said before
when Republicans say that Biden's
coveted stimulus caused inflation Trump
did two of the stimuluses or stimuli as
well as PPP which became a fraudulent
slush fund so the I think the the way I
would approach it is aside from debating
the money supply issue
if you blame Biden you have to blame
Trump at least two times more because he
did two of the coveted stimulus packages
and of course they don't because they
don't actually care or no it's just
about what can I get away with saying
and who can I criticize who's on the
left
right I mean
made the right word what I'm really
getting at is deficit
is a trillion dollar budget deficit in
four years
back it's funded not through borrowing
money not through raising taxes through
just creating money supply right that
alone has a huge catastrophic effect on
inflation it's no coincidence it started
when Trump is leaving yeah I I think
that the you know their modern monetary
theorists disagree with that premise and
are working hard to explain to us that
that's not actually the case let where I
will leave it is you're absolutely right
in assessing the conventional wisdom
around a lot of these issues and
Republicans are complete Hypocrites and
they're ignoring of it as it pertains to
Trump 100 right on that
right right so it's like you can't be a
New York Giants and a Philadelphia
Eagles fan at the same time it's like I
guess not I guess not that sounds tough
yeah
all right Bert thank you for the call I
appreciate it thank you David all right
there is Bert from Jersey great to hear
from you uh why don't we go next to a
treaties from Boston a treaties from
Boston welcome what's going on
hey David so I had a question about
Florida okay
okay so um it's no secret that I mean
DeSantis won by the highest uh
gubernatorial margin in Florida history
I think it was 1.5 million votes and in
his four years uh of
um in elected office he's especially in
the last couple years been basically
drunk with power you know with the don't
say gay Bill uh the Jerry bring a whole
list of things and just recently you
talked about how he wanted to
um or at least his State Senate wanted
to ban the Democratic Party from Florida
how
um
um he wanted to ban journalists from
criticizing him in fact I was just
listening to your colleague fair and
cousins last night saying that he who
lives in Florida is considering moving
because of this
um I basically wanted to ask the broad
question uh is Florida Beyond saving at
this point or do you think the pendulum
is going to swing back at some point no
I wouldn't say Florida is beyond saving
because what you have to remember is
that the number of Democrats in Florida
is insanely high as a result of the fact
that Florida's population is so uh large
and although that margin certainly was
was a record record for for the
Governor's race
um I would not in any way think about
abandoning Florida I think Florida is a
project where it has certainly started
to lean more red than it was you know in
the bush era for example
um but that I would I would be I think
it would be a disastrous idea for
Democrats to abandon it I think it's a
great opportunity opportunity the
pendulum does often swing back and uh I
mean listen if DeSantis became president
it could create a vacuum in Florida that
could actually be really good for
Democrats I think it would be a very bad
idea to say we're not we're not thinking
about Florida anymore
yeah I'm kind of in the same uh boat as
you I just I hear a lot of talk of it's
time to let Florida go no not in the
same way like and then yeah no I agree
with you I mean it has from what I
understand the fourth highest LGBT
population uh it's a state that Obama
won twice it has very high personal uh
person of color uh population so yeah I
agree with you that it's not Beyond
saving I just think there's there's
definitely a lot of panic among the left
yeah what to do Florida let's not panic
and let's keep working because I think
it's a it would be a huge mistake to
give it up uh A Treatise from Boston
great to hear from you today I do
appreciate it very much